die bürger glauben es gibt eine aktuelle
stunde zur eskalation der gewalt in
myanmar ist der bundesaußenminister
heiko maas der brutalität des militärs
kampfjets kreisen über friedlichen
demonstranten und menschen verbluten auf
offener straße erschossen weil sie für
demokratie protestiert haben erst
gestern kamen dutzende menschen dutzende
demonstranten zu tote zu tun
doch im november des letzten jahres
waren diese menschen voller hoffnung zu
den wahlurnen gegangen
mitten in der korona krise lag die
wahlbeteiligung im januar bei 72 prozent
mit überwältigender mehrheit haben die
wählerinnen und wähler ihrer de facto
regierungschefin und sand zum g erneut
das vertrauen ausgesprochen und die
militär partei hat eine deftige
niederlage erlitten und internationale
wahlbeobachter haben bestätigt dass die
wahlen grundsätzlich frei und fair
gewesen sind damit war eigentlich der
weg frei für die fortsetzung eines
sicherlich schwierigen demokratie
demokratisierungsprozesses in
deutschland und die europäische union
nach besten kräften unterstützt haben
doch dann kam der erste februar und der
versuch des militärs die uhr noch einmal
zurück zu drehen
meine damen und herren die frage um die
es nicht nur in deutschland sondern in
vielen teilen der welt geht ist was
können wir jetzt tun und dabei sind nach
unserer auffassung drei dinge
entscheidend erstens das was wir hier
und heute im deutschen bundestag tun
nämlich klar und deutlich machen dass
wir einen putsch nicht und niemals
akzeptieren werden
es ist deshalb ein wichtiges zeichen
gewesen dass der präsident des
bundestages den gewählten abgeordneten
in myanmar anfang der woche im namen
unseres ganzen hauses solidarität und
unterstützung zugesichert hat meine
damen und herren die sofortige
freilassung aller politischen gefangenen
und eine rückkehr zu den demokratisch
legitimierten institutionen das muss
eigentlich unsere gemeinsame haltung
sein
die europäische union und die g7 haben
sich auch auf unsere initiative hin
entsprechend klar geäußert aber auch der
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
und zwar mit china und russland hat
unsere zentralen forderungen unterstützt
und diese internationale geschlossenheit
die in zurzeit so viele krisen dossiers
nicht mehr vorhanden ist
die ist gerade in diesem fall unser
größtes pfund wenn es darum geht die
militärs zum einlenken zu bringen
doch meine damen und herren auch hier
worte alleine reiche nicht aus wenn
gleichzeitig in rangun und in anderen
städten auf unschuldige zivilisten
geschossen wird und deshalb haben wir
zweitens schon beim außenministerrat der
europäischen union im februar den weg
frei gemacht für gezielte sanktionen die
wir jetzt zeitnah beschließen können und
dabei zählen wir ganz bewusst auf die
entscheidungsträger des militärs und
auch weitere optionen wie etwa die
listung von wirtschaftsbetrieben des
militärs liegen bereits auf dem tisch
und können in kürze ergriffen werden
dabei ist muss uns allen eigentlich
eines ganz besonders wichtig sein dass
es sich nämlich ausschließlich um
maßnahmen handelt die eben nicht die
bevölkerung treffen die er ohnehin schon
unter der gegenwärtigen lage leidet und
deshalb meine damen und herren stehen
wir drittens von beginn an
im austausch mit unseren internationalen
aber vor allen dingen auf unseren
regionalen partnern um die lage
irgendwie einmal diplomatisch zu
entschärfen
und dabei ist es unser ziel und nicht
nur umsatz viel raum für einen
notwendigen dialog zu schaffen einen
raum den es bisher noch nicht gibt und
deshalb suchen wir dabei insbesondere
den schulterschluss mit den usa mit
kanada mit japan und mit australien vor
allem vor allem aber setzen wir auf
asien
denn der schlüssel zum dialog und auch
zu nachhaltigen lösungen der liegt in
der region mit singapur indonesien dem
aktuellen vorsitz brunei und anderen
stimmen wir uns zurzeit eng über das
weitere vorgehen ab das am dienstag ein
treffen der asian außenminister zu mehr
stattgefunden hat an dem auch vertreter
des militärs teilgenommen haben war ein
wichtiger schritt
und alle die sich in der region etwas
auskennen wissen des wegen des nicht
einmischung des gebotes dass ein
grundprinzip von asian ist das alles
keine selbstverständlichkeit gewesen ist
aber auch den asian partnern ist längst
klar dass der putsch in lima ein
rückschritt für ganz asien ist
und mehr noch er birgt eine echte gefahr
für stabilität und für wohlstand in
einer region die wie kaum eine andere im
fokus des amerikanisch-chinesischen
ringens um einfluss steht und auch das
erklärt warum sich länder wie singapur
und indonesien mit sehr klaren worten an
dass mir eine bayerische militär
gewendet haben auch das ist alles andere
als selbstverständlich in dieser region
der schlüssel
zur diplomatie der insbesondere auch in
den händen der un sondergesandten
schraner burgener liegt die bereits seit
aero india krise über zugänge zu allen
seiten verfügt auch den müssen wir
nutzen und deshalb unterstützen wir ihr
engagement nachdrücklich und wir fordern
auch endlich dazu auf dass es möglich
sein muss gespräche im meer zu
ermöglichen und zwar einschließlich
einem persönlichen gespräch mit aussagen
zum g
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
demokratisch gewählte politiker kann man
unter hausarrest stellen aber dadurch
wird eine militärdiktatur nicht legitim
facebook kann man abschalten doch die
stimmen der demonstrierenden trägt man
damit nicht zum verstummen sie suchen
sich einfach andere plattformen sowie
ist die jungen menschen mehr mag gerade
jetzt mit großem mut und auch mit großer
kreativität tun
protestierende kann man wegsperren aber
nie ein ganzes volk und die militärs im
mehrmaligen versuchen das rad der
geschichte zurückzudrehen
doch die menschen in mehr mal wollen
kein déjà vu der überwundenen
militärdiktatur weil sie frieden und
demokratie schon einmal erlebt haben
das einzig wirkliche gefängnis ist die
angst hatten zum g bereits vor einigen
jahren geschrieben und dieses gefängnis
haben die menschen in myanmar längst
verlassen und sie sollten uns an ihrer
seite wissen
vielen dank der bundesaußenminister
hatte maas lettische aktuellen stunde
eröffnet hat ja die brutale gewalt gegen
demonstranten in myanmar die eskaliert
anscheinend immer mehr mittlerweile
sollen ja polizei und armee willkürlich
in die menge schließen allein gestern
sagte die un seien 38 menschen ums leben
gekommen
in der aktuellen stunde jetzt am
rednerpult jugend braun für die afg
fraktion
frau präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe kollegen
generischer maske winkt ist generische
ist alles in ordnung alles deutsche
sprache liebe kollegen wenn sie nervös
werden dann merke ich dann merke ich
irgendwie scheint einen nerv bei ihnen
zu treffen dass sie mit deutscher
sprache ein problem hat das muss man mal
ganz deutlich feststellen deutschen
sprache bietet viele möglichkeiten und
ich werde die richtige in lima hat sich
das militär zurück an die macht
geputscht
demonstrationen werden gnadenlos
niedergeprügelt 38 tote allein heute
gemeldet viele schwer und
schwerstverletzten eine bedrückende
situation für die menschen in myanmar
dem früheren birma
die große mehrheit des volkes
unterstützt unser nzuzi in myanmar
konnte ich selbst erleben als sich
privat mehrere wochen dort war
wie das geht im händler und handwerker
in rangun restaurant pächter und fischer
am inle-see lehrer und arbeiter in
neuwagen
ich sprach mit menschen aus ganz
unterschiedlichen sozialen schichten
eine beeindruckende mehrheit unterstützt
sushi die meisten haben bilder von ihr
in den wohnungen am arbeitsplatz sie ist
die legitime regierungschefin ganz
deutlich war das zu spüren
bei den menschen im land nicht in einer
parteizentrale nicht bei einer deutschen
stiftung nicht bei einer ngo sondern bei
den normalen menschen in birma oder mehr
an war unser dschihad eine starke
stellung im volk sie ist die tochter des
freiheitshelden und sie hat sich einen
eigenen ruf als freiheitshelden erworben
jahrelange haushalt rest schon damals
unter einer linken militärdiktatur ihren
friedensnobelpreis 1999 ausdrücklich für
ihren einsatz für die menschenrechte
verliehen konnte sie nicht persönlich
dem hausarrest reiseverbot was war sie
damals für ein idol auch für die
altparteien und wie ist sie in den
letzten jahren verlassen worden von den
altparteien die demokratische
legitimierte wahlsiegerin in birma wurde
aus dem ausland mit erwartungen
überfrachtet die niemand absolut niemand
erfüllen kann
typisch für grünen und links grüne von
allen anderen übermenschliche leistungen
erwarten aber selbst nichts leisten im
vielvölkerstaat birma regieren in der
zwinger kooperation mit dem
kommunistischen militär das ist
hochkompliziert in birma regieren ist
nicht so einfach wie in prenzlauer berg
berlin mitte oder münchen schwabing war
latte macchiato und prosecco mal eben
kurz die welt retten aber linker hyper
moral ist das ja egal
die altparteien und die bundesregierung
verkennt die realitäten der welt
gemeinsam mit anderen linken regierungen
wollten sie haben sie und ihre regierung
zwingen mal eben mehr als eine million
bengalen einzubürgern menschen die nicht
zum staatsvolk gehören menschen deren
familien oft nicht aus birma stammen die
künstlich zu staatsbürgern gemacht
werden sollen
das dazugehörige diplomatische
sperrfeuer wurde vom islamischen staaten
block in den vereinten nationen eifrig
geschürt und die bundesregierung hat
mitgemacht das hat die legitime
germanische regierung geschwächt und nun
ist sie da eine lücke militärdiktatur
eine kommunistische diktatur der enger
bindung an die kommunistische führung in
peking
die versammelten altparteien hier im
bundestag müssen sich fragen lassen wie
viel verantwortung sie tragen an diesen
blutvergießen
eine mögliche lösung für myanmar könnte
in der politik der asian staaten liegen
dort bin ich ausnahmsweise mit herrn mas
einer meinung
die südostasiatischen staaten versuchen
den konflikt in myanmar zu befrieden
denn sie haben ein interesse daran dass
mir einmal ein starker partner bleibt
gegen den chinesischen einfluss also
auch gegen das kommunistische militär
dort liegt die lösung nicht den
grün-linken ansprüchen die unrealistisch
und unerfüllbar sind die afc ist die
einzige fraktion die konsequent und
trotzdem nicht unkritisch zu
friedensnobelpreisträgerin zu ski steht
auch unseren tuschi kann keine wunder
bewirken aber ihr staatsvolk erkennt
ihre politik mehrheitlich an die linken
regierungen europas haben diese frau im
stich gelassen die vereinten nationen
haben sie im stich gelassen die
bundesregierung hat sie im stich
gelassen
wäre es anders hätte sich das militär
nicht getraut die hand an das zarte
pflänzchen der demokratie in birma zu
legen aber die friedenspreis
friedensnobelpreisträgerin aung san suu
kyi wurde alleingelassen
sie ist und bleibt die hoffnung aller
demokraten wir die afg fraktion stehen
an der seite der friedlichen demokraten
in myanmar die asien starten jetzt schon
verschiedentlich angesprochen dass es
die vereinigung südostasiatischer länder
dazu zählen unter anderem brunei
kambodscha indonesien malaysia myanmar
eben singapur thailand und vietnam
die soll ja eine besondere rolle spielen
wenn es eben geht darum lösungen in der
region zu finden markus koob hören wir
jetzt mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss
für die unionsfraktion
frau präsidentin kolleginnen kollegen
nach der rede bräuchte man eigentlich
fast deutlich härteres als wasser zum
einstieg in die rede
aber da das nicht zur verfügung steht
kommen wir vielleicht mal wieder zum
thema zurück und reden hier nicht über
linke fantasien sondern über die lage in
myanmar und die ich bin total nicht an
grenzen
die bilder die wir aus myanmar in den
letzten tagen als leben und sehen sind
zutiefst dramatisch und sie eskalieren
immer weiter die anzahl der toten steigt
und das militär geht mit immer grösserer
härte und unbarmherziger härte gegen die
demonstrantinnen und demonstranten vor
und wir haben hier im bundestag schon
öfters zu hören mal gesprochen zu
kritischen dingen dass es auch für ihn
schon angesprochen worden
zur lage der herr und urin das in
myanmar wo wir zu recht sehr stark
kritik geübt haben
aber nichtsdestotrotz muss man sagen
haben wir nun mal in den letzten jahren
ein hoffnungsvoller demokratisierung
erlebt und diese hoffnungsvolle
demokratisierung hat im februar ein ende
gefunden
der militärputsch stehen wir jetzt sehen
erlebt oder verursacht bei uns ein
trauriges déjà vu dann in myanmar cups
nicht zum ersten mal einen militärputsch
sondern bereits drei mal vorher 1962
1988 1990 und jetzt eben auch 2021 und
das obwohl in sanssouci im jahr 2016 die
macht mit dem militär teilte ein
durchaus gewagte ein interessanter
ansatz ein kleines experiment eine so
ethnisch religiös und geschichtlich
diversifizierte gesellschaft im januar
in südostasien zu reagieren zu regieren
und dieses experiment ist nun leider
gescheitert das militär war nicht bereit
die wahlergebnisse zu akzeptieren die
aus diesen freien und fairen wahlen
heraus vorgegangen sind
dieses hybride demokratisches
regierungssystem dass wir erlebt haben
wurde zum unwillen der bevölkerung
geopfert und wir machterhalt der
militärs weiter zu sichern
die argumentation des militärs diese
wahlkommission habe versagt und es hätte
betrug bei den wählerlisten gegeben
und diese würden den weg zur demokratie
behindern ist auch in sich nicht
stichhaltig schon gar nicht weshalb
wahlbetrug zu einem notstand und zu dem
übertrag aller exekutive legislative und
judikative befugnisse aller ebenen auf
den oberbefehlshaber führen sollte das
ist grotesk den erstens müssten gemäß
der verfassung aus dem jahr 2008 wahl
angelegenheit von den zuständigen
behörden behandelt und gelöst werden und
zweitens ermächtigt artikel 48 17 der
verfassung nur den präsidenten in
absprache mit den nationalen
verteidigungs und sicherheitsrates
notstand ausgerufen
dieser rat hat nicht getagt aus
deutscher perspektive steht daher für
meine fraktion und mich fest wir
unterstützen die in myanmar friedlich
demonstrieren und bürgerinnen und bürger
die für die rettung ihrer demokratie und
die berücksichtigung des wählerwillens
auf die straße gehen er fordert den
rückzug des militärs die freilassung der
politischen gefangenen und einen wieder
einsetzen rechtsstaatlicher und
demokratischer strukturen sowie die
anerkennung des wahlergebnisses
wir begrüßen die eu sanktionen sind aber
auch für eine ausweitung offen sollte
das militär nicht einlenken eine
irgendwie geartete deutsche
zusammenarbeit mit dem militärregime
wird es in zukunft nicht geben
ich danke auch an dieser stelle
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
für seinen offenen brief an den
bisherigen und unter hausarrest
stehenden sprecher der volkskammer
versammlung die dort gefundenen worte
sind klar in der verurteilung und in der
solidarität und ich kann mich diesem
appell uneingeschränkt anschließen
aber es ist auch unsere aufgabe als
parlament und auch im auswärtigen
ausschuss über die eigentlichen grenzen
maß hinaus die rolle chinas in diesem
konflikt ins auge zu nehmen
der oberbefehlshaber der militärs in
myanmar und chinas außenminister yang yi
kamen noch drei wochen vor dem putsch
für intensive gespräche zusammen es gilt
zu vermuten dass chinas bedrohliche arme
länger werden nach nord korea und
hongkong erreichen sie auch mit hilfe
der abhängigkeit strukturen der welt
droht initiativ mittlerweile einige
staaten südostasiens dass hier auch nur
einmal erreichen ist daher
wahrscheinlich
ob es eine anweisung oder nur ein
einverständnis aus china zu dem putsch
gab kann in china ganz einfach erklären
indem es den putsch verurteilt und dazu
aufruft das demokratisch gewählte
parlament umgehend wieder einzusetzen
und zur rechtlich in ordnung
zurückzukehren
ein solches signal bleibt hier ging
bislang aber schuldig das vorgehen in
myanmar auch die anzeichen für chinas
rolle in diesem konflikt zeigen einmal
mehr wie wichtig es war dass die
bundesregierung im vergangenen jahr ihre
indopazifik leitlinien vorgelegt hat
denn auch wir haben ein interesse an
einem stabilen und vor allem friedlichen
indopazifik es ist grundsätzlich wichtig
und richtig unsere räumliche distanz zu
unseren freunden aus der region zu
verringern sie wertzuschätzen ihnen
beizustehen und sie eben nicht mit der
wirtschaftlichen übermacht chinas
alleine zu lassen
auch deshalb müssen wir endlich dafür
sorgen dass ja auch auf eu-ebene zu
einer einheitlichen und verbindlichen
indopazifik strategie gelangen vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit und die eu
kommission hat heute mitgeteilt dass die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit für mehr man
erst mal auf eis gelegt wird das soll
vor allem verhindern dass dem land nach
dem militärputsch finanzielle
unterstützung zukommt also der
militärregierung natürlich in dem fall
das hören wir den
entwicklungspolitischen sprecher für die
fdp fraktion christoph hoffmann damen
und herren
der brutale und inzwischen blutigen
militärputsch am ersten februar hat den
spalt der tür zur demokratie in myanmar
zugeschlagen 2008 gab es eine zarte
demokratisierung und damit verbundene
hoffnung für wirtschaftlichen aufschwung
das alles nach einer dunklen zeit der 50
jährigen diktatur die meinungsfreiheit
aber blieb auch in dieser zeit sehr
begrenzt so wurde ein cartoon über das
militär mit mehreren jahren gefängnis
bestraft ich konnte zweimal das land
besuchen
wir ja auch dabei der kollegen und wir
haben gesehen dass die deutsche
entwicklungszusammenarbeit projekte zur
dezentralisierung aber auch zur
förderung der demokratisierung und
wirtschaftlichen entwicklungen
installiert hat der spontane und nicht
abgestimmte abbruch der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit durch
minister müller war aus heutiger sicht
sicherlich ein fehler weil genau die
projekte der zivilgesellschaft gestärkt
wurden die jetzt um ihr überleben
kämpfen menschen in myanmar waren
enttäuscht von einem langsamen agieren
der eu beim engagement für die
demokratisierung vielleicht auch mit ein
grund dass zu wenige investitionen aus
der eu gekommen sind warum die tür zu
demokratie überhaupt wieder zufallen
könnte mir mal hatte alles im aus der
armut herauszukommen und den beispielen
der anderen asien staaten zu folgen
vergleichsweise gute bildung englische
sprachkenntnisse fleißige ehrliche und
liebenswerte menschen aber seit dem
militärputsch sind millionen menschen an
protesten beteiligt zivile ungehorsam
und generalstreik legen das öffentliche
leben lahm
unsere teilen der nld also der
siegreichen partei wurde inzwischen eine
eigene regierung bekommt aber hunderte
wenn nicht tausende demonstranten
journalisten sind in gefängnisse
gesteckt worden
viele unserer kollegen in lima gewählte
abgeordnete wie sie und ich wurden
direkt unter hausarrest gestellt und die
freien demokraten bedanken sich an
dieser stelle bei unserem präsidenten
schäuble
denn hatten scheibler sie haben mit
ihrem brief an den parlament sprechen
juni hat ein wichtiges signal gesendet
gewählte parlamentarier stehen zusammen
herzlichen dank dafür
das militär schießt mit scharfer
munition in die menschenmengen gestern
allein 38 tote
es sind junge frauen und männer für die
der traum von freiheit und
selbstbestimmung brutal mit einem
kopfschutz platzt es sind dieselben
militärs die die rohingyas im rock stage
vertrieben haben
und die internationalen reaktionen auf
den putz sind eindeutig gewalt wird
verurteilt die freilassung der
politischen gefangenen gefordert und
einzelpersonen werden bereits durch usa
und die eu sanktioniert deren vermögen
vermögen eingefroren
das ist gut so doch das reicht nicht wir
müssen mehr machen und dem militär
zeigen ihr seid nicht die zukunft und
ihr seid nicht mal ein generalstreik am
ars lässt sich nicht ewig durchhalten
deshalb brauchen wir schnelle neue
sanktionen als erster schritt würde ich
vorschlagen den militärattaché hier in
berlin einzubestellen auch zusammen mit
der botschafterin noch einmal um die
möglichkeiten eines dialogs zwischen den
beiden parteien auszuloten
es sollte aber auch klartext ticken über
den militärs gesprochen werden und sie
sollten dringend einen un waffenembargo
vorantreiben und die asian staaten bei
der vermittlung unterstützen das hatten
sie ja angedeutet vielen dank dafür
der zweite schritt wir sollten
konsequent sein und der der
militärregierung die anerkennung auf
internationaler bühne verweigern
lassen sie uns die demokratisch gewählte
regierung weiterhin als die einzige
vertretung des volkes anerkennen
und der dritte schritt das sind
wirtschaftssanktionen eng abgestimmt mit
unseren amerikanischen freunden
denn viele firmen im rohstoffsektor der
logistik und finanzdienstleistungen
gehören und finanzieren damit das
militär
damit würden wir die generale generäle
genau dort treffen wo es ihnen wirklich
weh tut nämlich bei den finanzen
es ist auch einige boden aus einem
anderen grund herr maas oder herr borel
es gibt 20 bewaffnete ethnischen
minderheiten im land und sie werden sich
bei weiterer eskalation den
demonstranten anschließen und das meine
damen und herren wird bedeutet
bürgerkrieg und das völlige abdriften
ins chaos ja vielleicht den untergang
des gesamten staates heute meine damen
und herren verneigen wir uns zu den
opfern
die im kampf für freiheit gefallen sind
wir trauern mit dem volk von mia
pittroff sagt christoph hoffmann hier
für die fdp fraktion ist ein signal es
ist zu beginn von heiko maas im
bundesaußenminister gesagt worden dass
natürlich auch hier der bundestag
stellung dazu nehmen zu den vorgängen zu
den gewaltsamen eskalation gegenüber den
demonstranten in myanmar hören wir für
die linke jetzt sehen darin vor einem
monat sind dutzende menschen getötet
worden und deshalb ist es auch an der
zeit dass der deutsche bundestag conny
haus ein klares zeichen setzt wir
verurteilen diese gewaltsame
machtübernahme des militärs im jama und
nach allem nach allem was wir wissen ist
der wohnt in die militärführung für den
putsch anführt angebliche
unregelmäßigkeiten bei den wahlen im
november 2020 schlicht vorgeschoben
hintergrund ist offenbar der
überwältigende wahlsieg der nationalen
liga für demokratie von anfang so shi
von dem die militärs ihre gemeinsam
herrschaft mit der nationalen
für demokratie im jama bedroht mehr als
1300 menschen sollen seit dem putsch
inhaftiert worden seien und deshalb
fordern wir auch hier die sofortige
freilassung aller politischen gefangenen
im iran
und nicht nur das hier fordern auch die
ausweisung des militärattachés von mama
aus deutschland und einen stopp der
waffenexporte an mia auch ich weiß es
ist ein waffenembargo gibt aber auch
über drittländer und über tochterfirmen
deutscher waffenschmiede im ausland es
ist wenn man sich anschaut wie
recherchen von greenpeace sind es wieder
auch deutsche waffen des herstellers
rheinmetall der für die maschinengewehre
die entwickelt hat die bei den geboten
bei den boten benutzt werden hier sind
immer wieder deutsche komponenten bei
waffen die im einsatz sind zu finden
auch jetzt ganz aktuell im jama und das
zeigt auch noch mal dass es ihnen zu
denken geben würde wenn waffen geliefert
werden andere länder vor zwei gingen
meine damen und herren möchte ich
allerdings im zusammenhang mit dem
putsch ausdrückliche warnung einmal vor
einer neuauflage von
wirtschaftssanktionen die am ende allein
die bevölkerung treffen und die nicht
gerade rosig den wirtschafts lage
dramatisch verschlechtern würden im jama
und es darf an die es in diesem
zusammenhang erinnert werden an den
aufruf der vereinten nationen die sagen
die einseitigen völkerrechtswidrigen
sanktionen weltweit sollten beendet
werden
und ich finde es kann nicht sein dass
erneut auf dieses verheerende
völkerrechtswidrige instrument
zurückgegriffen wird einfach nur um
handlungsbereitschaft zu simulieren
denn nichts als simulation ist es zum
zweiten will ich davor warnen den
konflikt im jama geopolitisch weiter
aufzuladen zu einem kampf des westens
gegen china um einfluss in diesem
die einzigen die dabei verlieren werden
sind die einwohnerinnen und einwohner
von jammer und deshalb auch noch mal zur
erinnerung
kein anderes land hat uns sans souci
öfter besucht als china china hatte mit
mama beste beziehungen es waren die
generäle die die öffnung des landes
wollten damit der chinesische einfluss
nicht zu groß werden würde und es waren
auch die generäle die die minderheiten
an der chinesischen grenze bekämpften
und china verdächtigten als
rückzugsgebiet für die aufständischen
dort zu fungieren und sicher es ist
richtig china ist der größte
handelspartner aber aus japan und
südkorea kommen die meisten
ausländischen direktinvestitionen und
nicht zuletzt hat china mit an songs ein
großes investitionspaket verabredet im
rahmen der road umweltinitiative im
letzten jahr
und all dies steht jetzt auf der kippe
und deshalb noch einmal wir sollten es
nicht zulassen dass der konflikt im jama
geopolitisch aufgeladen wird das hilft
den menschen im land keinen deut
mandanten und ein wonach zum umgang mit
uns am kotti sicher wir fordern als
linke ihre sofortige freilassung wie die
der anderen politischen gefangenen im
land
aber wir müssen auch sehen dass sie als
heldenfigur und projektionsfläche nur
wenig traut und es sei mir die bemerkung
erlaubt dass ein sorgsamer umgang auch
für andere gilt wie beispielsweise
alexei navalny dem amnesty international
den status des gewaltlosen politischen
gefangenen aberkannt hat mit verweis er
habe in der vergangenheit hass gegen
muslime geschürt
anfangs war es jedenfalls die gemeinsam
mit den militärs gegen die rinder im
süden des landes vorgegangen
und eine mitverantwortung für die
geschehnisse dort trägt sie taugt nicht
zur demokratischen helden
auch wenn wir ihre freilassung ihre
sofortige freilassung fordern wie die
aller anderen verhafteten und dem
militärputsch im jama klar und deutlich
verurteilt wäre der bundestag heute hier
diskutiert in dieser aktuellen stunde
über die brutale gewalt gegen
demonstranten in myanmar melden die
nachrichtenagenturen dass trotzdem ja
gestern 38 menschen zu tode kamen mir
mal das auch heute die demonstranten
wieder auf die straßen gegangen sind
beispielsweise in der größten stadt
rangun formieren sich wieder
demonstrationszüge alles wird gut
das stand auf dem t-shirt der 19
jährigen matthias in die gestern wie
tausende andere in myanmar auf die
straße gingen
sie protestierte gegen den putsch des
militärs für die anerkennung der wahlen
und für die freilassung der politischen
gefangenen
matthias sinn hat den tag nicht überlebt
sie wurde mit einer kugel in den kopf
ermordet mindestens 37 weitere menschen
sind allein gestern bei ihrem gewalt
fallen protesten getötet worden
mit allen mitteln und mit äußerster
brutalität versucht das militär die
proteste der mia marischen bevölkerung
zu unterdrücken von internetsperren über
tränengas bis hin zu scharfe munition
und gezielten schüssen in den kopf
soldaten posieren bei big talk mit
maschinengewehren und prahlen
unverhohlen
sie mit einer einzigen magazin ladung 30
menschen auf einmal töten können
videos zeigen wie erst helferinnen
brutal verprügelt werden
dieses militär dem die vereinten
nationen schwerste
menschenrechtsverbrechen gegen die
rohingya bis hin zu völkermord vorwerfen
versucht sich als retter der verfassung
und als legitime vertretung myanmar zu
präsentieren das ist an zynismus und
menschenverachtung nicht zu überbieten
und dem muss sich die internationale
gemeinschaft mit aller entschiedenheit
entgegen stellen
[Applaus]
offenbar hat der kunde das ausmaß des
widerstands in der bevölkerung massiv
unterschätzt
der gewaltlose aufstand gegen das
militärregime zeigt sich mit anhaltenden
protesten im ganzen land mit
generalstreiks mit zivilem ungehorsam
trotz der massiven gewalt geben die
menschen nicht auf sie protestieren mit
gesängen mit sprechchören mit moped von
voice mit auto blockaden mit plakaten
mit graffities und sie organisieren sich
trotz der internet sperren in den
sozialen netzwerken in hongkong in
thailand und jetzt in myanmar bieten
millionen vor allem junge menschen in
autoritären regimen und den
übermächtigen militärs die stirn
der wunsch nach demokratie nach
rechtsstaatlichkeit nach politischer
teilhabe und nach achtung der
menschenrechte ist omnipräsent
diese international vernetzten kreativen
und mutigen demokratiebewegungen zu
erleben macht leise hoffnung auf
langfristige veränderungen und es ist
unsere aufgabe dass wir uns hier an die
seite dieser mutigen menschen stellen
und sie mit all unseren möglichkeiten
unterstützen
[Applaus]
es freut mich es wurde auch schon
mehrfach erwähnt dass
bundestagspräsident dr schäuble den
militärputsch gestern so klar verurteilt
hat und sich an die seite der gewählten
parlamentarierinnen gestellt hat
angesichts der eskalation der gewalt der
militär unter muss die internationale
gemeinschaft muss die europäische union
und müssen auch wir hier das vorgehen
des militärs aufs schärfste verurteilen
der ausnahmezustand muss umgehend
aufgehoben werden und alle anderen
regierungsmitglieder müssen sofort
freigelassen werden und ebenso alle
politischen gefangenen
die eu muss jetzt individuelle
sanktionen gegen die verantwortlichen
des putsches verhängen und von der
bundesregierung erwarte ich da
konsequentes handeln jegliche
zusammenarbeit und damit die anerkennung
der militärs unter muss tabu sein
der militärattaché und regale general
von myanmar muss ausgewiesen werden und
das gilt auch für die sechs anderen
militärangehörigen in deutschland
gleichzeitig müssen die kanäle mit den
zivilen und demokratisch gewählten
vertreterinnen vertretern niemals
aufgenommen beziehungsweise
aufrechterhalten werden
und auch deutsche unternehmen sind in
der verantwortung dieser tage wurde
bekannt dass der
telekommunikationsspezialist dva aus
münchen zumindest indirekt das militär
mit telekommunikations technologie
unterstützt hier verlangen wir
umfassende aufklärung und gegebenenfalls
die beendigung der geschäftsbeziehungen
eine zentrale rolle muss jetzt auch
asien einnehmen wenn die bundesregierung
ihre neuen indopazifik leitungen ernst
nimmt dann muss sie aus asien ein wird
im dialog mit allen konfliktparteien
eine friedliche lösung und einen
übergang zu demokratischen verhältnissen
zu finden und dazu müssen auch alle
ethnischen gruppen gleichberechtigt
einbezogen werden und damit meine ich
auch die 100000 euro im jahr
die ins elend der flüchtlingslager in
bangladesch vertrieben wurden
everything will be ok das sollte nicht
nur eine hoffnung bleiben sagt margarete
bause die sprecherin für
menschenrechtspolitik von bündnis 90 die
grünen ja internationaler appelle die
gewalt zu beenden
die verein bislang ungehört ganz im
gegenteil das militär scheint ja jeden
tag brutaler gegen die massenproteste
vorzugehen individuelle sanktionen die
einstellung der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit um die
militär unter nicht zu unterstützen
morgen sondern auch der
weltsicherheitsrat sich mit der lage in
myanmar befassen
johann saathoff für die spd jetzt sogar
der präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die bilder und die nachrichten
die uns in den vergangenen wochen aus
myanmar erreichen
sie sind erschütternd wir sehen gewalt
gegen friedliche demonstranten
wir sehen einsatz scharfer munition
durch die sicherheitskräfte
und sogar das prahlen damit es gibt
viele tote und zahlreiche verletzte
unter den friedlichen demonstranten
wir sehen einschüchterungsversuche durch
das militär gegen journalisten die über
die proteste berichten wollen und wir
sehen und willkürliche verhaftungen in
großer zahl dieser bilder und
nachrichten führen uns deutlich vor
augen der militärputsch in myanmar
erfolgte gegen den ausdrücklichen willen
der bevölkerung die menschen wollen dass
miranda zurückkehrt auf einen
demokratisierung scores für den november
wahlen stehen und gestanden haben sehr
viele menschen in myanmar sind bereit
unter einsatz ihres lebens für
demokratische und rechtsstaatliche
entwicklung ihres landes einzutreten
wir sind wie wasser man kann uns nicht
aufhalten rufen sie auf den straßen
und wir stehen an der seite dieser
mutigen männer und frauen die gebrauch
machen von ihrem recht auf
meinungsfreiheit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen tödliche
gewalt gegen friedliche demonstranten
ist durch nichts zu rechtfertigen
es ist richtig und wichtig dass die
bundesregierung diese gewalt durch
sicherheitskräfte
sowohl öffentlich wie auch in gesprächen
mit vertretern maß auf das schärfste
verurteilt hat dass sowohl der hohe
vertreter der eu user borel der eu
generalsekretär görisch als auch die
außenminister der g 7 sich in diesem
maße geäußert haben zeigt wie breit
diese position weltweit getragen wird
in myanmar zeigt sich einmal mehr auf
der welt die kraft einer
zivilgesellschaft und die kraft der idee
der demokratie unsere gemeinde
gemeinsame forderung ist und muss sein
dass mir an mass sicherheitskräfte ihre
gewalt gegen demonstranten sofort denn
dass menschenrechte und das völkerrecht
in und von myanmar geachtet werden muss
dass die zahlreichen willkürlichen
verhafteten freigelassen werden dass die
festgenommenen spitzenpolitiker darunter
sanssouci und staatspräsident umgehend
freigelassen werden
das rechtsstaatliche prinzipien in
myanmar wieder respektiert werden und
dass die gewählte zivile regierung
wieder eingesetzt wird damit eine
rückkehr zur demokratischen ordnung
möglich ist dann braucht es einen
politischen dialog der den boden für die
rückkehr auf den pfad der
demokratisierung bereit hätte ich
begrüße dass wir das engagement sehen
für eine lösung der krise in myanmar von
den nachbarstaaten im rahmen der asia
es war ein erfolg dass am zweiten märz
zu einem informellen asian
außenministertreffen gekommen ist bei
dem die situation in myanmar thema war
und das ist beileibe keine
selbstverständlichkeit bei den anderen
dingen die wir in der asian geschichte
erlebt haben bundesaußenminister heiko
maas hat darauf ausdrücklich hingewiesen
und auch zu recht auch die rolle der
sondergesandten der vereinten nationen
für myanmar frau christine schraner
burgener
eröffneten hier an mass militär eine
chance auf einen politischen ausweg aus
der krise
über den dialog angebote zum dialog gibt
es also durchaus richtig ist aber auch
dass die eu sich zugleich darauf
vorbereitet jene personen mit gezielten
sanktionen zu treffen die direkt für den
militärputsch und damit für die
verbrechen auf der straße verantwortlich
sind
wir sind es mir an mass
zivilgesellschaft schuldig diejenigen
zur verantwortung zu ziehen die das
recht aller menschen auf freie
meinungsäußerung und demokratische und
rechtsstaatliche entwicklung
niederschießen lassen
es gehört zur ehrlichkeit dazu
festzuhalten dass wir auch in der
vergangenheit als mir immer auf
demokratisierung kurs war manches mal
höhere erwartungen an ihren maß
regierung hatten als diese zu erfüllen
bereit war der umgang mit der minderheit
der rohingya sei in diesem zusammenhang
genannt
ich habe bei meinen besuchen die
hoffnungslosigkeit der menschen vor ort
erlebt und werde sie wohl nie wieder in
meinem leben vergessen alle menschen in
myanmar verdienen die chance dass die
regierung ihres landes auf einem
demokratisierungsprozess zurückkehrt und
so ihren einfluss auf politische
prozesse auch ermöglicht dass wir nicht
zögern auch eine auf demokratisierung
schools steuern der regierung in quito
an ihre verpflichtung etwa zum schutz
von minderheiten zu erinnern haben wir
in der vergangenheit gezeigt wir sind
die wasser sagen die menschen man kann
uns nicht aufhalten wenn aus friesland
hat man gesagt take back oben kanzler
angaben
es ist unsere aufgabe sagen die menschen
hier zu demonstrieren
die menschen kämpfen um ihr land ein
land mit enormen potentialen und mit
enormen potenziale perspektiven und sie
kämpfen um eine um ein land in einer
region mit einer großen zukunft die
menschen setzen sich ein mit friedlichen
mitteln für frieden und demokratie
sie haben unsere hilfe verdient nach
nador muss nun demokratische offenheit
zurückkehren
herzlichen dank hoher auflösung sagt
jungen im auswärtigen ausschuss und hat
hierfür die spd fraktion gesprochen
für die fraktion der auftritt der
bundestags- vizepräsident hans peter
friedrich der hier die sitzung leitet
der ruft jetzt den nächsten redner auf
jens maier bitte sein für die fdp
fraktion
das kann ich mir nun zum einstieg nicht
verkneifen
zwei fraktionen dieses hauses beantragen
für diese stunde eine aktuelle stunde zu
der frage ob bestimmte politische
entscheidungen in diesem hause durch
machenschaften beeinflusst worden sind
ob es korruption mutmaßlich gibt oder
nicht
in der zahlenmäßig stärksten fraktion in
diesem hause und was macht die koalition
sie verschiebt diese debatte auf morgen
18 uhr freitagabend wo garantiert
niemanden dazu sieht und wo in diesem
hause nur noch relativ wenigen ausnahmen
werden weil sie sozusagen ihre
entfernten wohnorte nicht mehr nach
hause gehen über korruption soll hier
nicht geredet werden und das ist der
eigentliche skandal ist auch das einzige
aktuelle an dieser aktuellen stunde
stattdessen reden wir nun eben über
myanmar und von dort kommen schlechte
nachrichten nach einem demokratischen
interregnum hat das militär die macht
übernommen eine brutal
niedergeschlagenen demonstrationen der
hauptstadt zu 38 toten geführt eine
furchtbare zahlen
das muss verurteilt werden das steht
vollkommen außer frage
aber man muss sich auch fragen wie ist
es dazu gekommen
und dazu braucht man einen blick in die
neuere geschichte von jona
das ist ein vielvölkerstaat
zusammengesetzt aus vielen
völkerschaften die birmanen sind zwar an
sehen sich als staatsvolk
eben nur eines von vielen es ist ein
schwieriges erbe der kolonialzeit
das mahnmal zu tragen hat es hat dazu
geführt dass die briten seinerzeit die
völkerschaften dieses landes
gegeneinander ausgespielt habe sie haben
die birmanen unterdrückt dagegen die
völker des nordostens ist soll die
chemikalien in ihren alten herrschaften
belassen und sie gegen die birmanen
ausgespielt nach der staatsgründung 1958
jahr das jahrzehntelange kämpfe geben
gegen separatistische bestrebungen
insbesondere der karen region die ja
mehrheitlich christlich strukturiert ist
daher führte auch die erklärung des
buddhismus zur staatsreligion unsere
regierung nun vor jahrzehnten schon zu
zusätzlichen konflikten nicht nur medien
karin sondern auch mit den puhdys mit
den muslimischen neuen jobs es hat immer
wieder das ist von den vorrednern auch
schon gesagt nur intervention chinas
gegeben in die inneren verhältnisse von
myanmar aber auch in gewissem umfang von
thailand die thailänder allerdings haben
in der vergangenheit ihre eigenen
erfahrungen mit den besen machen müssen
die in den vergangenen jahrhunderten
immer wieder mit ihren armeen in
thailand eingefallen sind und sich dort
furchtbar aufgeführt haben
deswegen sieht das militär sich im teil
in burma oder in myanmar wie immer man
es nennen mag als garant der nationalen
einheit zum regierung gewissermaßen
legitimiert und das hat es auch
durchsetzen können im zuge der
verfassungsänderung von 2008 25 prozent
der sitze im parlament sind industrielle
für das militär reserviert
auch bestimmte einflussreiche
ministerposten die führenden militärs
haben sich ziemlich ungeniert
bereichert gegen das militär kann dort
praktischen niemand regieren
das hätte man vielleicht hinnehmen
können wenn das birmanische militär sich
verstanden hätte als eine entwicklungs
diktatur
das war es aber nicht es war eine
stagnation diktatur dass es immer noch
wenn man vergleicht den lebensstandard
in myanmar heute mit dem in thailand im
benachbarten zwar sehr ähnlich
strukturierte völker dann ist das
deprimierende zu sehen wie schlecht ist
in dem armen in völkern von myanmar geht
hat eine öffnung -strategie erlebt
politisch und auch wirtschaftlich sei
für 2012 aber eine demokratie im
europäischen sinne ist nicht entstanden
eine so genannte disziplinierte
demokratie
ein ausbruch auf den wahrscheinlich nur
militärs kommen können aber man muss
sich auch fragen muss eine
parlamentarische demokratie genauso wie
in europa das eigentliche ziel unserer
intervention sein muss überall alles
genau nach dem europäischen muster
strukturiert sein
ich denke das sollte man nicht einem
europäischen moral kolonialismus
überlassen sanktionen wie sie von der
eben geplant sind schreiben wir dann mal
noch mehr in die abhängigkeit von china
ich meine unsere leitlinie muss sein die
demokratischen kräfte in diesem land zu
stärken und die wirtschaftliche
um zu fördern das erste fordert die
zusammenarbeit mit den
oppositionsparteien im januar das zweite
aber auch die zusammenarbeit im
entwicklungspolitischen sinne mit der
verwaltung danke hin für aufmerksam
[Applaus]
inspire war dass die in dieser aktuellen
stunde kommt aus den reihen der cdu csu
fraktion und es ist der außenpolitische
sprecher der fraktion jürgen hardt
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
auch ich möchte mir zwei vorbemerkungen
nicht verkneifen
es ist gute tradition dieses hauses dass
wir wichtige außenpolitische
entwicklungen insbesondere dann wenn
menschenrechte in gefahr sind wenn
gewaltsamen umsturz zu erfolgen auch
immer zum gegenstand von debatten im
deutschen bundestag machen und es ist
auch gut dass der bundesaußenminister
die gelegenheit hat hier die position
der bundesregierung zu diesem thema
darzulegen und ich habe auch den
eindruck dass die versammelten
interessierten kolleginnen und kollegen
das auch genau so richtig sehen dass wir
heute diese aktuelle stunde hier zu
diesem thema durchgeführt haben als
koalition beantragt haben und die hat an
die adresse meines vorredners möchte ich
sagen also ich finde das offen gesagt
ziemlich absurd hier zu reduzieren über
gute und schlechte diktaturen und auch
noch in dieser absolut herrschaftlichen
chauvinistischen attitüde zu sagen
demokratie ist ja gar nicht was für alle
die in asien die wissen ja sowieso nicht
wie man das macht das finde ich eine art
und weise
eine art und weise des umgangs mit
anderen völkern und den rechten anderer
menschen und den menschenrechten andere
menschen auf der erde
das spricht bände und wirft ein
bezeichnendes licht auf ihre partei mit
ihrem sinn so und ich könnte noch
hinzufügen ich habe das gefühl die afd
betrachtet auch in deutschland nicht
geben für demokratiefähig nämlich wenn
man nicht daran glaubt was sie erzählen
dann ist man auch kein demokrat so vor
ziemlich genau zehn jahren hat die
deutsche bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
der damalige oppositionsführerin und
friedensnobelpreisträgerin aung san suu
kyi die volle unterstützung deutschlands
bei der demokratisierung des landes
zugesagt das war ein damals viel
beachteter internationaler im akte in
die bundesregierung vorgenommen hat und
der deutsche bundestag hat dann in einer
debatte die auf andere auf grundlage
eines antrags den die damalige koalition
aus union und fdp eingebracht hatte
festgestellt dass wir in lima den
äußerst seltenen fall beobachten dass
sich an die diktatur offenbar von sich
heraus wandelt das haben wir damals 2012
so gehofft und erwartet und wir hatten
in den letzten neun jahren auch den
eindruck trotz aller schwierigkeiten und
rückschläge die es gegeben hat dass
dieses land auf einem guten weg war das
was jetzt anfang februar in myanmar
geschehen ist ist ein herber rückschlag
es ist ein kompletter ein kompletter
kurswechsel dieses landes auch der
militärführung dieses landes die ja vor
zehn jahren selbst diese im
demokratisierungsprozess nicht im wege
gestanden hat und wir fordern erstens
dass man das wahlergebnis anerkennt dass
die wahlen
die parlamentswahlen die letzten
parlamentswahlen ergeben haben es gibt
keine vernünftigen zweifel daran dass
dieses ergebnis gerecht ist und im
übrigen auch die stimmung im land ist ja
so dass die niederlage der militär
partei und der große erfolg der partei
unseren schieß und ihrer unterstützung
entsprechend auch richtig gewesen ist
wir fordern ein ende der gewalt gegen
friedliche demonstranten
wir haben die große befürchtung dass die
eskalation der gewalt die ja
mittlerweile mehrere dutzend todesopfer
gefühl herbeigeführt hat und wo wir
leider schreckliche bilder in den
sozialen netzwerken quasi stündlich
beobachten müssen dass diese gewalt dass
dieser gewalt einhalt geboten wird weil
natürlich sonst die gefahr besteht dass
das land insgesamt noch stärker in
gewalt versinkt als das bereits jetzt
der fall ist weil gewalt im zweifel
natürlich auch gegen gewalt provoziert
und das muss unbedingt vermieden werden
das land war 50 jahre abgeschottet von
der wirtschaftlichen und
gesellschaftlichen entwicklung der erde
es ist seit etwa zehn jahren auf den weg
der öffnung gewesen es hat dem land gut
getan das land hat im übrigen durch
seine geographische lage unsere
bodenschätze auch eine ziemlich gute
voraussetzung zu einem prosperierenden
partner der weltökonomie und der
bergwelt völkergemeinschaft zu werden
die geografische lage mit der langen
küste zumindest ozean im nordosten
angrenzend an china ist ja nicht nur
verschiedene unseren export bemühungen
sondern auch für alle anderen richtung
china exportieren wollen durchaus eine
gute perspektive um einen langen seeweg
durch die malaga straße marler straße zu
vermeiden
deswegen ist das was das militär jetzt
gemacht hat auch etwas dass das land
nicht nur politisch sondern auch
wirtschaftlich deutlich zurückwerfen
wird und ich setze darauf dass die asian
vorankommt ich glaube aber dass auch der
g 7 gipfel im sommer ein klares zeichen
setzen muss und ich glaube dass
sanktionen der europäischen union und
deutschlands
insbesondere dann gegen einzelne
personen insbesondere dann eine wirkung
entfalten wenn sie im schulterschluss
der g7 nationen entsprechend
durchgeführt werden und deswegen
plädiere ich dafür dass wir diesen
schulterschluss mit den demokratie in
dieser zeit suchen herzlich das wort hat
als sex ist der kollege dietmar nietan
spd fraktion sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir erleben dass auch jetzt
wahrscheinlich in diesen minuten
unschuldige menschen die für ihr recht
auf demokratie auf die straße gehen
in myanmar kaltblütig ermordet werden
und dieses leid nutzen die vertreter der
fdp fraktion um sich in ihrer
ideologischen verblendung an den
sogenannten altparteien abzuarbeiten
oder darüber zu schwadronieren
ob vielleicht auch eine entwicklungs
diktatur hinnehmbar ist wie zynisch und
menschenverachtend muss man sein wenn
man dieses leid für diese ideologischen
kampf gegen missbrauch
ich möchte ihnen ein paar zitate nennen
von nachrichten die mich erreicht haben
von menschen die ich kenne in myanmar
einen deutscher touristen guide aus
jahren schrieb gestern
ich weiß nicht mehr was ich sagen soll
ich bin verzweifelt menschen werden auf
offener straße ermordet von terroristen
in polizei und militär uniform
keiner ist mehr sicher terroristen haben
das land übernommen und töten jeden
widerstand im keim ab im wahrsten sinne
des wortes
es ist nicht in worte zu fassen und ein
früherer schulkamerad von mir schrieb
mir gestern
hier geht es um eine kleine gruppe macht
und geld hungrig keiner aber auch keiner
im land wird diese kleine schmutzige
armee gruppe haben
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen kollegen genau darum geht es
eine clique von mächtigen männern
militärs betrachtet seit jahrzehnten das
land myanmar als ihr persönliches
eigentum
sie beuten das land auf sie bereichern
sich selbst anstatt die verschiedenen
gruppen und ethnien miteinander zu
versöhnen und das land zum wohle aller
dort lebenden menschen in eine bessere
politische soziale und wirtschaftliche
zukunft zu führen
einige dieser generäle glauben immer
noch dass sie ihre alte ordnung mit
enthemmter gewalt gegen friedlich
demonstrierende menschen wieder
herstellen können und nicht nur mit
tränengas und schlägern sondern auch mit
gezielten tödlichen schüssen in kopf und
brust
das ist unerträglich liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
doch diese gewaltorgie wird den
diktatoren nichts nutzen denn alles hat
seine zeit und jetzt ist die zeit
gekommen dass die menschen in myanmar
sich nicht mehr einschüchtern lassen
sie werden sich weiter dem terrorregime
widersetzen
deshalb sage ich den herren generellen
hier von diesem rednerpult des deutschen
bundestages in aller klarheit
stoppen sie ihren terror lassen sie alle
politischen gefangenen frei
ihre zeit ist schon lange vorbei geben
sie die macht dahin wo sie hingehört in
die hände des souveräns und das ist
niemand anders als die über 50 millionen
bürgerinnen und bürger - was immer
passiert kann uns die wir in freiheit
und demokratie leben dürfen nicht kalt
lassen
wir dürfen nicht nur ohnmächtige und
mahnende beobachter bleiben sondern
müssen schnell und entschlossen handeln
daher begrüße ich ausdrücklich die
klaren worte unseres
bundesaußenministers und auch unseres
bundestags präsidentin zu den
putschisten in myanmar und
selbstverständlich begrüßen wir es in
der spd bundestagsfraktion das auch die
europäische union sanktionen auf den weg
bringen will
die gezielt die verantwortlichen für
diesen militärputsch und deren
wirtschaftlichen interessen treffen
sollen aber diese aktion müssen
sanktionen müssen jetzt kommen sie
müssen zeitnah kommen und sie müssen
zielsicher angewendet werden und im
engen schulterschluss mit der neuen
us-regierung müssen eu und auch die
internationale gemeinschaft den druck
auf die militärs und ihren netzwerken
spürbar erhöhen
dazu muss falls das noch nicht geschehen
ist das gespräch mit den asian staaten
gerade jetzt weiter besucht werden die
hier eine besondere verantwortung tragen
und die kolleginnen dagdelen hat völlig
recht es darf keine geopolitische
aufladung dieses konflikts in dieser
region geben aber das heißt nicht dass
wir tatenlos zusehen wenn china myanmar
zu seinem spielball machen möchte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was neben dem
druck auf die putschisten jetzt wichtig
ist wir müssen immer wieder deutlich
machen dass wir auf der seite der
friedlichen mutigen menschen in myanmar
stehen die zurzeit jeden tag ihr leben
für freiheit und demokratie riskieren
diese akteure der demokratischen
zivilgesellschaft brauchen längerfristig
eine klare strategie und eine breite
internationale unterstützung
denn es ist doch gerade diese mutige
zivilgesellschaft so wie wir sie jetzt
erleben die in großer solidarität
zusammen stellt die ja die
zukunftsoption für dieses tolle land
sein kann
doch jetzt erstmal müssen wir alles tun
um die gewalt der herrschenden zu
stoppen damit ein neuer dialog beginnen
kann und dieses land braucht dringender
denn je einen dialog zwischen den
politischen lagern zwischen ethnischen
gruppen
wir alle wissen das wird eine
herkulesaufgabe doch wenn der moment
gekommen ist sollten wir da sein und
hilfe anbieten
bis es soweit ist müssen wir jede
gelegenheit nutzen den herren generellen
unmissverständlich klar zu machen dass
ihr terror gegenüber dem eigenen volk
für sie nicht folgenlos bleiben wird
abschließend möchte ich sagen angesichts
des großen leids in myanmar möchte ich
diesen generellen immer wieder zu rufen
ihr werdet nicht durchkommen beendete
das morden und gibt dem volk seine
freiheit herzlichen dank
der april von dietmar nietan die
forderung
hier ist viel im auswärtigen ausschuss
hat für die spd gesprochen jetzt hören
wir schon auf dem weg zum rednerpult
hier mario mieruch einer von
mittlerweile ja sieben fraktionslosen
abgeordneten hier im bundestag
herr präsident meine damen und herren
die vorgänge die bilder die uns aus mir
nahe erreichen sind furchtbar und aufs
schärfste zu verurteilen und müssen
sofort aufhören sich aber heute hierhin
zu stellen und das kind zu verteilen
nachdem es ihnen gefallen ist ist etwas
zu einfach denn die zivilregierung viren
maas hat mehrfach in den vergangenen
jahren die hand in richtung deutschland
ausgestreckt und um hilfe gebeten
aber deutschland ging es offensichtlich
nie wirklich um ein tieferes verständnis
für dieses kleine land das
jahrzehntelange militärherrschaft
brechen musste eine militärherrschaft
die auch die nobelpreisträgerin auge
sanssouci nicht alleine ohne hilfe
abschütteln konnte und dass die militärs
an den schaltstellen sitzen so wie es
heute hier beklagt wird ist ja keine
überraschung das ist ja nicht erst seit
heute so die verantwortung dieses
parlament es hätte darin bestanden
diesem land zu helfen und genau und
objektiv zu prüfen was vor ort
eigentlich geschieht
man hätte mit der botschafterin auch in
rohem konflikt reden müssen statt sie
wie eine aussätzige zu behandeln
stattdessen haben sich im sommer 20 18
ist mittlerweile fast drei jahre her
nur frauke petry und ich mit ihr
getroffen um uns einmal wirklich auch
aus ihrer sicht darstellen zu lassen wie
sich die verhältnisse im land darstellen
und eine außenminister gabriel
er hat es sogar nach geschafft damals
die regierung bei einem asien treffen zu
düpieren indem man nur kurz aufsetzte
und ohne direkten kontakt einfach
weiterfuhr
sie habe sich zu keinem zeitpunkt für
die in arakan aktiven dschihadisten
interessiert die den fragilen
vielvölkerstaat die stabilisierten
und sie haben es nicht für nötig
gehalten deren vorgehen zu ächten
stattdessen habe man hören waagerechte
dann sanktionen beschlossen ohne mit den
offiziellen vertretern hier im lande zu
besprechen
und man hat der exilregierung keine
hilfe angeboten um den rückfall in genau
dieses autors autoritäre regime zu
verhindern
das wäre aber vielleicht der richtige
weg gewesen um auch die wo hinterfrage
nachhaltig zu lösen
über die hier im haus augenscheinlich
öfter gesprochen wird als über die
uiguren oder die weltweite
christenverfolgung kurzsichtige
moralische selbst über bereicherung
scheint einigen hier wichtiger zu sein
als eine objektive bewertung des
spannungsverhältnisses in welchem dieses
land steht nicht nur zu china und welche
geostrategische bedeutung es dort hat
denn den konflikt den haben wir längst
sie messen wieder einmal mit zweierlei
maß und das prägt ihr handeln ich
fordere sie daher auf nicht nur in sich
zu gehen und zu überdenken wie man mit
mir einmal in der vergangenheit
umgegangen ist
ich fordere bundestag und
bundesregierung gleichermaßen dazu auf
sich halt eben klar und deutlich hinter
die demokratische zivilregierung zu
stellen und mit einer symbolischen geste
das verhältnis zwischen unseren beiden
ländern wieder zu versöhnen und daher
fordern wir als lka ein asyl angebot an
ruhm sans souci vielen dank die arroganz
könnte der nächste redner ist für die
cdu csu fraktion
der kollege doktor volker ullrich
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wenn wir auf die bilder
aus myanmar schauen sind wut und trauer
unsere gefühle
nach un-angaben sind allein gestern bei
protesten 38 menschen ermordet worden
und trotz der schlimmen vorkommnisse
gehen die proteste weiter
und die menschen lassen sich nicht
entmutigen
davor haben wir respekt und deswegen ist
es wichtig heute debattieren um klar und
deutlich zum ausdruck zu bringen
wir stehen an der seite des tunesischen
volkes
und wir bringen klar und deutlich
folgende forderungen zum ausdruck die
gewalt muss und die täter aus dem
militär unter sind konsequent zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen
die politischen gefangenen hafteten sind
sofort freizulassen
der ausnahmezustand ist aufzuheben und
das burmesische parlament muss sofort
seine tätigkeit wieder aufnehmen können
um eine demokratisch legitimierte
regierung zu stützen das muss
grundkonsens in diesem haus sein und der
umstand dass ausgerechnet am ersten
februar am tag der konstituierenden
sitzung des burmesischen parlaments der
militärputsch erfolgte zeigt die
besondere missachtung auch der
militärjunta für demokratisch
legitimierte volksvertreter und deswegen
brauchen wir in allen parlamenten der
welt ein deutliches zeichen der ächtung
und der distanzierung der ereignisse in
myanmar am 8 november 2020 hat das volk
gesprochen und man hat einer großen
mehrheit der nationalen liga für
demokratie unter der führung von an
die führung des landes an vertraut
obwohl nach der halb auto ried ehren
verfassung mia mars 25 prozent der sitze
unabhängig vom wahlergebnis für das
militär reserviert sind kam es trotzdem
zu diesem großen erdrutschsieg für die
nationale liga und das bedeutet dass
hier ein klarer auftrag für die führung
mehrmals liegt und deswegen ist die
militärjunta aufgerufen diesen willen
des volkes zu respektieren und die in
der tat umzusetzen und wir stehen auch
an der seite des tunesischen volkes weil
wir wissen dass dieses volk eine lange
leidensgeschichte hat bereits 188 wurden
proteste sehr blutig niedergeschlagen
damals ohne soziale medien ein fast von
der weltgemeinschaft vergessen das
ereignis aber heute muss es anders sein
es muss erfolgreich sein muss gewaltlos
sein
die junge generation lebt diesen protest
und trägt ihn über die sozialen medien
in die welt hinaus und deswegen muss
deutlich werden dass sie sich unsere
solidarität sicher sein können
sie kämpfen für demokratie für freiheit
und für den respekt vor menschenrechten
und überall dort wo menschen für
menschenrechte und demokratie und
freiheit eintreten muss auch dieser
bundestag bis solidarität zur seite
stehen und deswegen ist es wichtig heute
mit sagt diese debatte zu führen meine
damen und herren
und wir müssen auch deutlich zum
ausdruck bringen was wir uns erwarten
eine resolution des un-sicherheitsrats
gemeinsam unseren freunden
in nordamerika den vereinigten staaten
und kanada personenbezogene sanktionen
gegen die führenden köpfe der
militärjunta einfrierung von guthaben um
deutlich zu machen dass auch ökonomisch
konsequenzen hat wenn jemand so mit
seinem eigenen volk umgeht aber bei der
frage in via marke dass noch mehr via x
grenzt an thailand an indien und china
es ist ein starkes land im
südostasiatischen raum asiatischen raum
und in diesem bereich der welt
kristallisiert sich gerade das zeigt
auch der blick nach hongkong eine große
frage heraus was ist stärker freiheit
und demokratie oder unterdrückung und
ein autoritäres regime und die antwort
die die weltgemeinschaft darauf geben
muss ist eindeutig die antwort kann nur
sein dass menschenrechte freiheit und
demokratie ende stärker sind und auch
dieser kampf dem augenblick in den
straßen von wir mal ausgetragen und
deswegen noch mal wichtig das signal wir
stehen an der seite des volkes im
herzlichen dank das wort hat für die spd
fraktion der kollege frank schwab
[Applaus]
herr präsident verehrte damen und herren
mit lang lang sowie an 210 winter tut
mir antun
die nahrungs an jäger und andré man
könnte auf die idee kommen die namen der
opfer der ermordeten der letzten tage
und stunden hier vorzutragen das sind
sie aber in dem fall nicht sondern sind
die namen der täterinnen und täter ich
glaube dass es aber auch wichtig damit
man sich die namen merkt und schaut wie
man international damit umgehen kann
die usa hat sie bereits auf eine
sanktionsliste gesetzt und es sind
dieselben vertreterinnen und vertreter
der militärs die übrigens in den haag
schon vor dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof stehen und das will ich
dann doch noch mal sagen ich glaube man
kann opfer gegen nicht gegen opfer aus
recht auf rechnen aber es ist schon in
farben herr braun wenn sie hier die
argumentationsmuster genau der militärs
übernehmen die von bengalen reden die ja
eigentlich gar nicht zu mir gehören
würden wenn sie über die rohingya reden
wenn sie genau das argumentationsmuster
übernehmen was die grundlage und der
hintergrund des völkermordes ist den
genozid der an tausenden menschen verübt
wird und 200.000 sind vertrieben worden
und wirklich das sollten sie hier
unterlassen bei aller politischen
auseinandersetzung der völkermord an den
roh hinter ist dramatisch und schlimm
und deswegen ist es richtig dass der
deutsche bundestag diesen auch
verwurzelt und es sind dieselben
militärs
deshalb militärs die diesen völkermord
verantworten und die jetzt auf
unschuldige menschen schießen lassen sie
gezielt erschießen lassen und sie sind
verantwortlichen sie müssen dafür auch
zur verantwortung gezogen werden
die lage und die entwicklung ja das ist
wirklich ein internationales drama diana
hat mehr aufmerksamkeit bekommen als
viele anderen andere länder der welt das
hat was zu tun sicherlich auch mit dem
charisma mit von nahrung sun tzu chi und
es hat sich ja am ende leider das
bewahrheitet was sie befürchtet hat sie
hat ja befürchtet dass am ende die
militärs wieder pushen könnten und hat
sich wahrscheinlich auch deswegen in der
frage der rangers zurückgehalten
man könnte es aber auch andersrum sagen
das was sie versucht hat nämlich am ende
ein völkermord nicht völkermord zu
nehmen hat sich am ende für sie eben
auch nicht ausgezahlt sondern es hat
trotzdem am ende diesen putsch jetzt
gegeben und es hat sich auch nicht
ausgezahlt so viel kritische betrachtung
muss schon sein dass sie es versäumt hat
ihre partei die nationale liga
entsprechend neu aufzustellen ich war
auch in myanmar und habe vertreterin
vertreter dieser nationalen liga
getroffen
es war eine liege auch alter männer und
die partei das leider nicht geschafft
das was wir jetzt auf den straßen den
können an jungen menschen an
zukunftshoffnung an zukunftsperspektive
auch mit in diesem demokratischen
prozess einzubringen und am ende sind
eben auch die vertreter von rohan just
die ja früher in dieser partei ein
führender stelle waren zum teil an
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
ausgeschlossen worden und das hat zu
großen enttäuschungen effekten
jedenfalls auch geführt jetzt haben wir
aber die situation dass eine
demokratisch legitimierte führung des
landes geputscht wurde und dass wir
sehen dass junge menschen dagegen
aufbegehren eine zivilgesellschaft wie
man sich das glaube ich nicht hätte
vorstellen können wie sich das auch die
militärs nicht hätten vorstellen können
das macht große hoffnung und es stimmt
tief traurig traurig zu sehen wie die
menschen dort tagtäglich gerade am ort
werden was ist das was wir tun können
und wir tun das ja in großer einigkeit
hier glaube ich auch die dinge auf den
tisch legen die frage hierzu diskutieren
deutlich zu machen niemand kommt um
genannten davon alles zu tun um ihre
partei und die demokratisch legitimierte
regierung zu unterstützen dass sie
wieder ins amt kommt zu verurteilen dass
diese gewalt gerade stattfindet zu
fordern dass politische gefangene
freigelassen werden dass die verfolgung
eingestellt wird und in der tat in eu
sanktionsmechanismus zu nutzen den wir
dankenswerterweise mittlerweile haben in
abstimmung mit den vereinigten staaten
von amerika die zum glück zurück sind
auf der weltbühne solche verbrechen
entsprechen nicht zu denken sondern
entsprechend sie anzuprangern
und wir müssen auch gemeinsam alles
betreiben um das verfahren vor dem
internationalen strafgerichtshof
voranzutreiben weil nochmal man trifft
sozusagen immer die richtigen es sind
dieselben die den völkermord an den
ranger begehen und es sind dieselben die
gerade unschuldige menschen erschießen
lassen lassen sie uns hoffen dass mit
dem internationalen prozess aber vor
allem mit dem engagement der jungen
menschen im land die demokratie im jahr
schnell zurückkehrt vielen dank sagt
frank schwabe hier der obmann im
ausschuss für menschenrechte und
humanitäre hilfe
hierfür die spd gesprochen und jetzt
haben wir noch einen redner dieser
aktuellen stunde von bayer beantragt von
den koalitionsfraktionen und von der
cdu/csu-fraktion können wir jetzt hier
martin patzelt
wir haben jetzt eine stunde lang mit
betroffenheit die geschehen ist im eimer
geschildert aufgenommen wir haben sie
mit partie aufgenommen wir haben danach
gefragt wie ist das zu beurteilen und
wir haben versucht zu sagen das können
wir eigentlich tun mich persönlich immer
fällt immer und das wird manchen in
diesem haus zu gehen
eine große ohnmacht eine aktuelle stunde
wie schon öfter bei solchen
gelegenheiten
denn was das wieder gehen wir zu unseren
tagesgeschäft über was sollen wir auch
tun wie können wir dieses leid die
gewalt das morgen die herrschaft sucht
von führenden personen der
weltgeschichte wie können wir die
wirklich begrenzen
als mitglied der menschenrechtsausschuss
überfällt mich diese ohnmacht immer
wieder gehören woche für woche in der
sitzungswoche das elend aus allen teilen
der welt und wissen dann doch nicht so
richtig was wir machen können unter
brown ich möchte ihnen entgegentreten
und der mir auch
es ist nicht so dass die deutsche
regierung oder die deutschen
parlamentarier nichts getan hätten
allein das schreiben von unserem um
staatspräsidenten an den sprecher des
parlaments macht deutlich dass der enge
beziehung gewachsen waren dass wir im
austausch kann es oder erwähnen dass die
bundeskanzlerin gleich zu beginn der
präsidentschaft von st
die die kontakte gesucht hat in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit haben wir
zusammengearbeitet es ist einfach nicht
wahr wenn man zu sagen will
ich denke an die vielen briefe und
kontakte die wir als menschenrechtler
zumindest geknüpft haben aber frau dr
wer kann denn wirklich wer kann denn
wirklich ermessen was das für eine
drahtseil wanderung ist der präsident in
dieser verfassung und mit den
erbschaften die sie angetreten haben mit
einem hochgradigen nationalismus im land
mit einem hass auf die ruinen dass wir
wissen ja schon dass bei uns im land an
aktionen gegen flüchtlinge gegen fremde
ist und diese präsidentin von der wir so
beeindruckt haben weil sie den
friedensnobelpreis bekommen hat sie
stand dann unter die kritik weil sie
versucht hat auf diesem drahtseil weiter
zu gehen dass es gerissen
das ist gerissen weil das militär nicht
mehr ertragen konnte dass die
entwicklung vielleicht in eine
demokratischere situation hinein geht
die sie so nicht wollen nicht nur
vielleicht weil ihre freunde weniger
werden sondern weil sie auch im alten
welt
und da sind wir wieder ganz nah auch in
unserem land dem alten weltbild
verhaftet sind und nicht verstehen dass
eine multikulturelle gesellschaft wird
die meyer man ja gerade ein vorbild sein
könnte
mit der vier völker situation dass diese
multikulturelle situation die zukunft
der welt ist anders können wir nicht
spießig und gericht zusammen leben und
ich würde mir wünschen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen dass wir als
menschenrechtler
in diesem parlament doch eine stärkere
stimme bekommen ich empfinde uns immer
wie ein anhängsel
ja wir tun etwas vielleicht sind wir
auch das feigenblatt des parlaments
vielleicht sind wir in einzelfällen dann
auch mal erfolgreich aber eigentlich
müsste unsere regierung mit uns
intensiver zusammenarbeiten eigentlich
müssten die anderen ausschüsse
intensiver mit uns zusammenarbeiten
sozusagen als güte kontrollieren ob wir
das was wir in unserer politik und den
einzelnen bestrebungen machen
tatsächlich dann unseren
menschenrechtlichen vorstellungen
entspricht
denn den abgleich zwischen
wirtschaftlichen und diplomatischen
interessen erlebe ich immer wieder dass
menschen rechtliche interessen ganz
zurücktreten
das will ich kein vorwerfen die sind ja
auch wichtig aber wenn wir uns so
schmücken und wenn wir eine solche
stunde halten dann müsste uns das mehr
mehr beeindrucken und wir müssen sagen
wir wollen uns dieser selbstkontrolle
auch unterwerfen warum war natürlich
alle menschen und vor allem jungen
menschen in der welt uns zum vorbild
nehmen sie wollen zur frei leben
sie wollen so wirtschaftlich erfolgreich
leben sie wollen mit einem allgemeinen
wohlstand leben wie wir es tun und sie
schauen wie wir miteinander umgehen
woher unser wohlstand unsere freiheit
resultiert und ich kann ihnen nur
wünschen dass das wasser von dem sie
sprechen dass es überall hin rinnen wird
dass es auch die harten strukturen und
die haben menschen erreichen und
erreichen wird denn ich will das noch
ein bisschen relativieren von insidern
höre ich dass das gar nicht so ist dass
zwar die mehrheit und insbesondere
jungen menschen auf seiten der präsident
entstehen
aber das ist auch eine große gruppe von
nationalisten
und von totalitären menschen gibt die
die militärs sehr wohl die stange halten
und jetzt als bürgermilizen durch die
straßen gehen und die bürger
kontrollieren und die ermächtigung dazu
haben ihnen die handys weg nehmen sie
verhaften sie in die gefängnisse bringen
dass da eigentlich im land selber und
nicht nur in der generalität eine
stimmung dass die vielleicht sogar zum
bürgerkrieg führen könnte
darauf müssen wir achten und was können
wir tun ja neben dem was hier schon
gesagt wurde will ich nur noch mal an
mass an man werde ich das öfter erlebt
habe wie schwer es ist ein visa zu
bekommen
ein visa für menschen die auf der flucht
sind
einer meiner vorredner ein klapptisch
wer hat das gesagt wir müssen diesen
menschen auf asyl bieten und zwar ohne
große schwierigkeiten
immer wieder erleben wird wie schwer das
ist aus solchen situationen heraus in
deutschland eine zuflucht zu finden
ich denke an die botschaft in prag als
ddr sich aufgelöst hat
wie vielen menschen wurden dort
ausgenommen so schlimm muss es nicht
kommen
aber ich war bei meinen reisen in
vietnam und auf den philippinen habe ich
auch erlebt wie sehr sich unsere
botschaften tour kollege auch der letzte
redner fünf minuten konnte letzter satz
konkret dann tatsächlich hilfesuchenden
menschen auf die hilfe zu geben dass wir
nicht nur mitnehmen und dann ist das
patenschaftsprogramm herr präsident sie
gestatten das patenschaftsprogramm
parlamentarier schützen parlamentarier
es ist immer schwer parlamentarier dafür
zu finden wir haben viel viel mehr
parlamentarier die schutz suchen zu als
kolleginnen und kollegen die ihm helfen
und schülern zu nehmen das ist der
letzte redner in dieser aktuellen stunde
einhellig hier im haus die verurteilung
der polizei und militär gewalt gegen die
demonstranten in myanmar und ein
deutliches zeichen und ein signal wollte
der bundestag hier sitzen